what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today I'm going to be going
over the four yong-chol aka the Four
Emperors of the sea and their powers the
yonkou are considered to be the
strongest living pirates in the world
we will technically be talking about
five yong-chol since one replaced
another as we'll get into I'm primarily
doing this video because the topic
excites me but if you guys want to see
more videos like this about the warlords
the straw hats or the Marines let me
know by smashing down like button and
leaving a comment below we have about
four one-piece videos on this channel
and they've all received excellent
feedback so it's about time for another
one if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future videos for daily anime facts
and important updates follow us on
instagram at anime uproar there will be
wrong as spoilers in this video now
without further ado let's jump into it
let's start with Edward Newgate aka
white beard
the man was widely known as a strongest
man in the world and the man closest to
the one piece after the pirate Kings
death at 72 years old white beard was
one of the most epic old dudes in anime
before his death in the Battle of murine
fourth which was probably my favorite
arc in all of one piece it's worth
mentioning that like to other Janka on
this list
Charlotte Lin Lin and Kato Whitebeard
used to be a member of the rocks pirates
they were led by Captain rocks and they
were considered to be the strongest
pirate crew until the rise of gol D
Roger the fact that at one point 3 out
of 4 young Co who rule over the new
world were from the same crew shows how
strong he must have been white beard
possessed the Gudda Gudda know me
aka the tremor tremor fruit the mangaka
one piece Eiichiro Oda stated that this
fruit was the strongest paramecia fruit
sangoku proclaims at one point that with
this devil fruit white beard has the
power to destroy the world the power
lets white beard produce shockwaves that
can travel through practically anything
air water and land the shock waves can
cause tsunamis and earthquakes the shock
waves can be unpredictable so allies
have to be cautious around the user and
not get in his way
white beer was pretty much able to split
an island in half creating a giant chasm
to separate the pirates who were on one
side from the Marines who were on the
other he uses the power to
pretty much destroy the Navy
headquarters but the power is not
limitless the Navy has created walls
stronger than steel that won't shatter
as a result of the gudaguda no me power
white beard can create vibrations around
himself to protect himself because of
this ability LPG can't freeze him white
beard can concentrate his power into a
small orb or a quake bubble around his
hand to increase its power he can create
contained but powerful explosion type
attacks he used this attack to beat a
giant vice-admiral with one blow he
destroyed his helmet like it was nothing
he can surround his spear with a quake
bubble and use it to extend its reach he
can mow down enemies far away in this
fashion perhaps the most interesting
power is white beards ability to grab
the air and pull it by doing so he
tilted the entire battlefield at marine
for white beard can also use all three
types of haki including armament haki
observation haki
and conquerors haki which is the rarest
of all armament haki allows him to
increase his defense and attack and
allows him to injure logia users that
are otherwise immune to physical attacks
observation haki lets the users sense
someone's presence when they're
concealed or far away lastly conquerors
haki is the most rare only one in
several million people have it it allows
the user to exert his will power over
others which can cause people to
straight-up faint and animals to run
away whoever possesses conquers haki
possesses the attributes of a king so
you could say that they are a born
leader
when white beard was younger and
stronger his hockey was strong enough to
match that of the pirate kings without
even touching the clash of haki alone
created insanely strong winds white
beard did eventually die but he remained
standing nonetheless he was old and sick
so despite how impressive he was a
marine Ford we should keep in mind that
that was not white beard in his prime
black beard stole white beards opie
devil fruit along with this title of
yong-chol thus in theory he can learn to
use all white beards moves centered
around his devil fruit but he is still
inexperienced and has not mastered the
fruit to the extent that white beard had
so let's look at Marshall D th aka black
beard and his powers in more detail next
black beard is
one of the most fascinating characters
in anime in the battle at marine for
every side seem to lose except
Blackbeard who managed to come out as
the winner he is 40 years old after the
time skip and he is the first person in
history to wield two different devil
fruits now that he possesses
whitebeard's power to destroy the world
along with his own dark dark fruit he
doesn't seem that crazy when he says
stuff like I'm invincible
and I'm the greatest after he stole the
power he even proclaimed that his era
was beginning just like rocks had his
era and Goldie Roger had his Blackbeard
is all the more entertaining because
there seems to be some truth behind his
ridiculously ambitious proclamations we
went through the powers of the gudaguda
know me when we talked about white beard
so let's focus on the Yami Yami no me
aka the dark dark fruit here it is set
to be the most dangerous power in the
history of all devil fruit powers it's a
logia type fruit and it lets Blackbeard
become a darkness man allowing him to
create control and transform into
darkness Blackbeard can use his darkness
power to suck in an entire town
according to Blackbeard his dark gravity
power compresses objects with infinite
power and crushes them he can then
release the wreckage from his darkness
interestingly enough the dark dark fruit
doesn't allow Blackbeard to avoid damage
like other logia users as he points out
to ace the darkness sucks in everything
whether it's punches blades bullets fire
or lightning his body absorbs all pain
and that pain is even amplified in the
process but in exchange for that the
dark tower fruit lets him pull in the
actual body of devil Pro users and when
he's touching that he can absorb their
powers so when he punches ace while
holding him with his other arm ace can't
use his flame flame fruit to avoid the
attack as we find out during the battle
of murine ford black we could also
absorb other people's devil fruit powers
for himself as we saw when he stole
white beards devil fruit like we are so
powerful that he actually managed to
give the yong-chol shanks the scars he
has over his left eye and shanks insists
that it wasn't because he was careless
it was because Blackbeard is that
dangerous shanks even tells the
legendary white beard not to go after
Blackbeard
of how dangerous he is out of all of the
uncle's bounties Blackbeard's is
actually the lowest at two billion two
hundred forty seven million six hundred
thousand berries however it should be
noted that Blackbeard was often the one
to understate and hide his true power he
willingly hid behind white beard when it
suited his purposes in my view
Blackbeard's bounty although high does
not adequately reflect how dangerous he
actually is it's also interesting to
note that Blackbeard was powerful enough
to be a commander for the white beard
pirates even before he had a devil fruit
but he declined preferring to stay
low-key for the time being
Blackbeard is able to use armament and
observation haki marco has also stated
that Blackbeard's body is odd and that
maybe explains how he could use to devil
fruit powers at the same time people say
Blackbeard doesn't even sleep Blackbeard
survived attacks from Ace a
confrontation with shanks a quake bubble
around his head from white beard and
more and he survived without any
significant lasting injuries it's clear
that his body is superhuman
however what is perhaps even more
dangerous about him is his mind his
ability to strategize makes him in my
view very dangerous and very interesting
he was able to outsmart everyone he set
up a vent so that he'd be able to get
the dark dark fruit which he was willing
to patiently wait for for about two
decades the level of patience is insane
and all that time he was able to
convince everyone that he was not
ambitious at all then he became a
warlord of the sea so that he could
break some ridiculously opie people out
of prison and add unto his crew he set
things up so that the Pirates would
fight the Marines while he swooped in to
take white beards devil fruit powers
when the old man was almost dead he got
his way and he was smart enough to not
fight shanks when he showed up and ended
the war his mind and patience are what
got him to this point he's like a chess
master on the world stage and seeing his
plans come together is one of the most
interesting things about the entire
series in my view he is definitely a
worthy villain for Luffy to eventually
face off against
next let's look at keidel of the beasts
known as the strongest creature in the
world his bounty
is four billion six hundred eleven
million one hundred thousand Berry's the
largest of any living pirate people
often say that if it's a one-on-one
battle Qaeda will win which is why he's
known as the strongest creature when
white beard was alive kaito actually
tried to attack him but shanks
interfered clearly Kaito is not only
strong but brave as well although I
seriously doubt he's as good at
strategizing as Blackbeard he has one of
the best introductions he is introduced
as a man searching for a place to die we
are told that he's been caught by the
Navy or enemy ships no less than
eighteen times he was tortured time and
time again and lived as a prisoner when
they tried to hang him the rope snapped
when put under the guillotine the blade
cracked then he attempted to kill
himself by jumping off from Sky Island
but he survives not even Kaito can kill
himself
that's how invincible he is I don't know
if there's been a better introduction to
an Opie character than this Kaito isn't
strong because he wants to be he
practically views his overpowered as an
annoyance which is pretty hilarious he
has a deserved reputation for being
unable to die the fight against Kaito
and Luffy was a significant one we are
used to protagonists fighting struggling
but ultimately overcoming their
opponents however this is now what
happens during this fight not even close
Luffy hits keidel with many attacks and
Kaito is ultimately not hurt by them
then Kaito hits Luffy with his club once
and Luffy is out cold
it's refreshing to see that pure
willpower isn't enough to overpower a
strong opponent sometimes it doesn't
happen often and Shonen manga but Kaito
was able to brutally embarrass are shown
and protagonist and that shows how
strong and special he is now let's get
to his devil fruit which is a mythical
zone type fruit it allows him to
transform into a giant blue eastern
dragon he can shoot heat blast from his
dragon mouth that can cause devastating
damage when Kaito clashed with big mob
they both used conkers haki that rare
haki that allows the user who possesses
the qualities of a king to exert his
willpower over others as mentioned it
can straight up caused weaker willed
people to faint or large creatures to
run away shanks whitebeard Luffy and
others
also possess conquerors haki although
Luffy's had no effect on Kaito when
Kaito and big maan clashed the heavens
split open just like when white beard
and shanks clashed interestingly enough
they seem to be pretty evenly matched in
battle they eventually decide to team up
and take over the world together after
that they plan to finish their fight to
the death
next let's look at the 68 year old big
mom aka Charlotte Lin Lin the yahko who
clashed evenly with the strongest
creature in the world her own bounty is
4 billion three hundred and eighty eight
million Berry's big mom definitely
doesn't come off as calculating and
patient as Blackbeard she has been known
to destroy entire countries over sweets
almost everyone including her own
children fears her when she's angry like
hide oh she was born powerful rather
than trying to become powerful when she
was five she accidentally killed a large
bear by smacking it making taka Maura
from Hajime no Ippo look like a joke she
even broke the bones of a giant by
trying to slap a mosquito like hide over
overpowered nough seems more like an
annoyance than a goal even as a kid she
could break a skill giant sword with her
fist and then defeat him I could keep
going but you get the point
she's very very strong her double fruit
is a paramecia type called soda soda no
me
aka soul soul fruit the fruit allows her
to take the soul of whoever she touches
and take years away from their lifespan
obviously if she takes enough years the
victim will die right then and there
the ability is super Opie but there is a
loophole if you have no fear of death or
big mom then it seems like you will not
be affected by the devil through powers
she can also put Souls into inanimate
objects or animals these new
anthropomorphised beings are known as
homies and you can see them all around
total and it's noteworthy that big mom
cannot put Souls into corpses or other
people the fruit can also produce little
incarnations of pure soul that go around
collecting and distributing Souls for
big mom big mom used parts of her own
soul to create three special homies that
are far more powerful than the rest
these homies include Zeus the
thundercloud that is summoned by her
left hand Prometheus the Sun that is
summoned by her right hand
and Napoleon who takes the form of big
mobs hat the Sun can create flames the
cloud can create lightning bolts and
together they can manipulate the weather
her hat can turn into a blade that she
can wield or that can move and attack by
itself her hat can also relay
information to her that it receives from
other homies Zeus the cloud can be read
and on and it allows big mom to travel
at high speeds prometheus can also
engulf the Polian in flames increasing
the power of the sword furthermore the
sword can release powerful destructive
shockwaves in short big mom and her
powers are definitely larger than life
big mom can also use all three haki
types conquers haki armament haki and
observation haki her armament haki can
easily withstand a punch from luffy's
powerful fourth gear
aka gear for now let's get to red haired
shanks finally he's definitely one of my
favorite characters and I love the way
Oda has constructed him red haired
shanks is currently 39 years old in the
manga and he was 27 years old in chapter
1 he used to be a member of the Roger
pirates when he was younger serving
under the pirate king himself what
fascinates me the most about shanks is
how Oda is able to build so much hype
around him without revealing too much
about his powers we didn't see anything
crazy from his 27 year old self although
we didn't know what it was back then we
did see him use conquerors haki to scare
off the seeking after it took his arm
off later when we see him approaching
white beard his hockey power is enough
to make many of white beard skilled
pirates pass out when white beard and
shanks clash just as when Kaito and big
mom clash they split the heavens
suggesting their otherworldly level of
power I know he was only 27 at the time
and was not as strong as he is now but
still I loved how such a strong dude
chose not to absolutely wreck and it
after he spilled a drink in his face
here we have a guy who must be one of
the strongest pirates in the world even
at the age of 27 and he led a random
bandit make him look like a weakling as
Luffy put it even at 27 he had nothing
to prove to anyone he had no ego about
the situation he understood that
needless killing doesn't make you a man
just because that guy threw a drink in
shanks his face it doesn't mean
he actually heard shanks in anyway
shanks understood that one can only be
offended if they choose to be offended
and he was above all that at the young
age of twenty seven truly an amazing
character and role model even as a 39
year old shanks is the youngest
yong-chol and i think i probably speak
for most of us when i say that shanks
showing up in putting a stop to the war
at marine fort was one of the most epic
and amazing moments in anime albeit a
lot of people were injured but it's
amazing how none of the Marines or even
Blackbeard dare to challenge shanks if
that doesn't set him up as being
extremely powerful I don't know what
does it's noteworthy that shanks even as
a young Co could get an audience with
the five elders who are the public heads
of the celestial dragons and world
government that is how much sway shanks
holds we also saw that near the end of
the battle at marine Ford he was able to
effortlessly stop a kindness punch with
his sword and haki we know that he was
able to prevent fellow young Hokkaido
from attacking white beard before he
lost his arm shanks dueled mihawk the
strongest swordsman in the world and
survived
what's more Kaito has a devil fruit big
mob has a devil fruit Blackbeard has two
devil fruits but shanks doesn't possess
any devil fruit powers this just makes
all of his accomplishments and his
reputation seem all the more impressive
so that is what we know about shanks not
only can he use all three types of haki
he arguably has the most powerful haki
we've never seen him go all out but that
just builds all the more hype around his
character anyways that is it for today's
video thanks so much for watching
obviously there is much more to be said
about all of these characters so if you
want to see me go into detail on one
specifically let me know in the comments
and smash that like button because I'll
start working on the next one peace
video as soon as we reach 5,000 likes if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial ring that notification
bow so you don't miss future videos for
daily anime content and to help decide
what videos I make in the future boss on
instagram at anime uproar a special
thank you goes to our patrons over on
patreon who help us survive YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible first and foremost I
want to thank our the one tier patrons
the ones who stay on top all clans
Steven and Greta allo Lana
and the world Steelers the school bus
and Tyson Kirino and I can't forget our
pro hero to your patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason
Wilson Kings eldress $30 beat Anatole
Cassatt Suki alpha do angel Cruz team
sparty 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor just
come alone the Emperor Taku Timothy
Edward Vargas Jeanne d'Arc Joel Stanton
and jccc Wacha thank you all so much if
you enjoy our work you can support more
of it by going over to patreon
accomplish anime uproar and becoming a
patron today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon accomplished and may uproar link
in the description if you're interested
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you will get the
same great benefits thanks for
everything and until next time see us
space cowboy
[Music]